hi everyone let's get started so today
we'll be covering the things that we
didn't get to last time with regard to
metal learning and black box audit
patient approaches to med learning and
then we'll cover topics in optimization
based approaches so before we get
started a couple of reminders so first
homework one is due on Wednesday next
week and the homework assignment is now
out and yeah encourage you to get
started on that early and then also the
first paper presentations and
discussions of papers will be happening
on Wednesday this week and so please
show up so we can discuss those papers
and also kind of be a part of the
discussion for the students that are
presenting that day as well okay so as I
was mentioning today we'll first start
by actually by recapping the
probabilistic formulation of medal
earning that I mentioned at the end of
lecture last time and then cover kind of
a general recipe for different meta
learning algorithms and cover black box
out of patient approaches these kind of
these two things on the topic of
homework one will you'll be implementing
a black box approach to better learning
and then we'll be talking about
optimization based mental learning and
this will actually be part of homework 2
and the rest of homework 2 will be
covered in the next lecture on Monday
next week ok so first let's recap from
last time so we were talking about kind
of a more intuitive or probabilistic
view to these meta learning algorithms
and in particular we can view meta
learning as a process of learning a set
of meta parameters theta that summarizes
your meta training data such that you
can solve new tasks quickly and what
this Mediterranean data looked like was
you had a range of tasks 1 through n and
for each task you had a training data
set and a test set and the training days
that had K data points the tests that
had K data points and so in particular
what meta learning was trying to do was
to optimize for us at a meta four set of
meta parameters that maximized the
likelihood of those parameters and so a
particular you could view kind of the
motor training processes optimizing for
these medicham
and the adaptation process as adapting
those parameters to compute a set of
parameters Phi that can solve a new task
given a training dataset for that task
and the meta parameters that you learned
and so you could essentially view I kind
of this adaptation process as this
function f that's taking in a training
data set and producing a new set of
parameters Phi star and kind of under
this view of of that a patient process
you can kind of view meta learning as
optimizing for the Mediterranean breeze
such that the TAS specific parameter is
do well on health out data your test set
where the top specific parameters are
computed according to your training data
set for that task okay so this is like
essentially the probabilistic view on
meta learning where you can view kind of
the Mediterranean process as trying to
optimize for these these kind of prior
parameters such that adaptation leads to
good performance all right so now I'd
like to talk about how we actually kind
of design algorithms that perform this
optimization basically at a more
mechanistic level and in cover kind of
how you actually go about trying to
implement some of these things so I'm
particularly like can we think about a
general recipe for meta learning
algorithms and before I actually cover a
general recipe for the algorithms
themselves we need to have a sense for
how we're actually going to be
evaluating these meta learning
algorithms so I want to first talk about
how to evaluate a metal learning
algorithm and I kind of the first thing
worth mentioning here the first thing
that we should mention is the the
Omniglot dataset so this is a data set
that was proposed by Brendan Lake at all
in 2015 and it actually really kind of
exemplifies some of the the weak points
with neural networks with regard to
learning from small amounts of data so
this data set has six feet 1,600
characters from 50 different alphabets
here are some examples of the of the
data set so there's different alphabets
like Hebrew Bengali etc and each
character has
20 instances so unlike something like em
nest that has a few number of characters
and a huge number of data points per
character and in many ways this is sort
of like the transpose it has many
classes and a few examples per class and
one of the things that I think it's
quite appealing like to a dataset like
this is that the statistics of those
days that are in many ways more
reflective of the types of things that
we see in the real world for example if
you kind of are trying to learn how to
recognize Forks for example you're not
going to see thousands and thousands of
different types of Forks
you may see a a wide range of objects
but you're only going to see per object
a small number of instances of that
object they were out your lifetime okay
so this dataset is kind of has kind of
the breadth of classes and and a small
number of examples per class and they
propose a few different ways you could
try to use this data set so they
proposed both few shot discriminative
learning as well as few shot generative
learning problems and in particular what
these look like is the future
discriminative learning is given a few
examples of new characters can you learn
to classify between those characters and
the derivative problem is likewise given
a few examples of some characters can
you actually generate new instances of
those characters and they essentially
showed that things like deep neural
networks struggle at this sort of
problem if you're going to be training
them from scratch because if you're only
training them on a few examples we know
that deep neural networks to best when
you have large number of examples and
initial approaches towards this kind of
problem actually predating the Omniglot
dataset itself instead used things like
Bayesian models and nonparametric so in
order to solve this problem great so
this is kind of one kind of canonical
example for a meta learning data set and
there are wide range of others that have
also been used for medal earning more
recently and these include things like
the mini image net dataset the c-4
dataset cub celeb a and a number of
others
and all these days that's kind of the
goal is to given a small number of
examples be able to learn something from
that small data set okay so this is this
is kind of on the data set size these
are the kind of data set so you can use
to evaluate a few top learning algorithm
know how do we actually go about
evaluating an algorithm on these data
sets and so this is actually gonna look
a lot like the test that I gave you on
the first day where your goal is to
classify new examples from a small data
set and so in particular let's say that
we have a five-way one-shot image
classification problem and in particular
we could have one example of five
different classes shown here way means
the number of classes shot means the
number of examples per class and then
your goal is given these five examples
classified new examples as being among
one of the five classes on the left okay
so this is the few shot learning problem
and in meta learning our goal is to be
able to leverage data from other image
classes in order to solve this problem
just like baby'll deleverage the
mediterranean data set that i was
mentioning before in order to learn a
few shot cost if i got fire that can
kind of learn from these data points on
the left so the way that we can do that
is we can structure the data into
training sets and test sets just like i
was mentioning before where these is
going to mimic what you're going to be
seeing at test time matching better
training time in meta testing time so
you can take five other image classes
classes and break it into a training set
and a test set and do this for a wide
range of other image classes that you've
seen in the past these will be your
training classes and you'll perform
méditerranée across these training
meditating the classifier such that
after it sees the images on the left it
can successfully classify images on the
right and then critically after you do
this you'll test it on holdout image
classes as shown on the top and it will
essentially be able to perform this view
shot learning problem and this isn't
specific to image classification you can
replace image classification with a
regression problem language generation
problems skill learning problems kind of
as I alluded to in previous lectures
each of these tasks shown as rows is
essentially a machine learn
problem okay so any questions on this
set up okay yeah yeah the new ones here
is that in in multitask learning your
goal would be to try to solve all of the
training tasks shown in this in this BA
in the gray box
whereas in meta learning your goal is to
use these training tasks in order to
solve new tasks with small amounts of
data so kind of being able to actually
evaluate on new tasks and quickly learn
new tasks is the critical difference
between the two problems okay so kind of
more broadly and more generally we can
kind of view the meta learning problem
from a more mechanistic standpoint and
so in particular if we say supervised
learning is trying to learn a mapping
from X to Y given input-output pairs we
can view meta supervised learning as
trying to learn from a data set to make
where this data set contains K
input-output pairs for a K shot learning
problem to make predictions about new
test data points X test so our goal is
to I kind of produce a function that
takes as input a training data set and a
test input and produces the label
corresponding to the test input so at
this more mechanistic view of meta
learning is essentially that we want to
learn this function f function f that
takes in the training data set and the
test input and produces the label all
right now the way that we learn this
this function is through a Mediterranean
data set which contains a set of tasks
or a set of data sets where each data
set consists of XY pairs where you'll
use at least K to be used for the
training data set and at least one
additional data point to be used to
measure generalization to actually train
it such that it does well on new data
points now why is this you use view
useful so we kind of saw the
probabilistic viewpoint before one of
the nice things about this pretty clear
problem statement is that it reduces the
problem of meta learning to
of designing and optimizing this
function f once you kind of design this
function f and optimum and kind of
decide how you want to optimize it then
you've created meta learning algorithm
okay how does this connect to the
probabilistic viewpoint well you can
view supervised learning as doing
inference over parameters given a data
set similarly you can view the
adaptation process of meta learning as
doing inference over your TAS specific
parameters Phii given a training data
set and and a set of meta parameters and
the meta learning optimization as doing
maximum likelihood in friends over the
meta parameters over all of your
training tasks okay any questions on
kind of the problem set up before we get
into algorithms yeah yeah that's a good
question
so typically algorithms assume that you
know you know something about the K that
you'll be evaluated on a test time so if
you're going to evaluate on 10-shot
learning or 100 shot learning then
you'll train for those values and you
could train for depending on the
algorithm you could train for exactly
the value that you think you're gonna
have a test time or a range of values
such that it can adapt to a range of
data set sizes yeah
so your question is what if you don't
know the test tasks that you're going to
be evaluated on yeah so generally the
assumption here is that the the test
task that you're being evaluated on is
from the distribution the same
distribution as the training tasks and
well some some algorithms do better than
others when you break that by break that
assumption and I'll talk about that a
bit more in the second half of this
lecture there's also kind of this online
setting where incrementally adding tasks
and that's a setting that has been
explored a little bit I don't talk a
little bit about probably as when we
talk about lifelong learning in the
course and then we'll also talk a little
bit about set like later in the course
about settings where you just know
nothing you just have like an unlabeled
data set and how you might be able to
try to construct tasks automatically was
there another question yeah
so you're asking is it required to use
the same network structure as supervised
starting or I guess well we'll get into
the the kind of what different
architectures you can use for different
algorithms later in the lecture and then
if you still have the question you can
ask it it may be towards the end okay
great so the general recipe for what an
algorithm looks like is basically what I
alluded to before is choose some form of
this function that is that could be
probabilistic or it could be a
deterministic function as I mentioned
before where you're going to be
outputting a set of top specific
parameters given a training data set and
your meta parameters and then once you
choose the form of this then you need to
just figure out how you want to choose
to optimize your parameters data with
respect to your meta training data set
and this this choice is usually somewhat
relatively straightforward using
standard neural network optimizers okay
so this is kind of the general form and
most meta learning algorithms very based
off of the first point basically how do
you actually design this function that's
going to infer how specific parameters
and so the first class of approaches
that we'll look at are going to be
considering can we treat this this
distribution is an inference problem and
in particular neural networks are pretty
good at doing things like inference and
so can we just treat this function as a
neural network and this is where what
I'm gonna refer to as blackbox
approaches come in so what these
blackbox annotation approaches is they
essentially just train a neural network
to represent this function right here
this a neural network that's going to be
outputting parameters given a training
dataset and a set of meta parameters and
so first for now we're going to be using
a deterministic or point estimate of
this distribution and we'll kind of get
back to Bayesian approaches
a couple of luxuries and the way this
looks like is you can have some neural
network that has parameters theta it
takes as input the training data it
could take it as input in a sequential
fashion or I could take it in kind of
all as one batch and it outputs a set of
tasks specific parameters Phi I and then
you have a separate neural network
that's parametrized by Phi I that makes
predictions about test data points and
this is essentially your the test state
you can basically train this train
everything using your test is that di
test and so this is like really simple
and some of the nice things about this
is we can just train it with standard
supervised learning so we can say that
the we want to be able to maximize the
probability of the labels under the
distribution that G is producing for all
the test data points and for all of the
tasks in your Mediterranean data set so
essentially what you're doing is this
your training this neural network such
that it outputs parameters that I
represent an accurate classifier so if
you denote this right-hand part as the
loss for a set of parameters Phi given a
test data point then you could
essentially view this optimization as as
the the loss function between the
parameters that are outputted a loss
function that takes funded parameters
that are output it by F theta evaluated
on your test dataset averaged over all
of your tasks okay any questions on this
yeah
[Music]
right so when you evaluate your model
you're given a new task and so you're
given a training data set for a new task
and so what you do is you're you for
your test task you basically pass on
that train data set into your network f
theta and and produce your parameters
for that task yeah so in this case the
during the meta training process the
parameters theta are learned and the
parameters Phi I are somewhat
dynamically computed per task so in this
sense Phi is almost treated more as
activations or a 10 or a tensor rather
than actual parameters which is somewhat
of an interesting concept the yeah
basically you can Bob back propagate the
loss with respect to Phi into the meta
parameters theta yeah
yeah that's a good question so the
question was relating to the basically
should you be like in the homework
you're also passing in Y tests as input
to the right-hand side and then zeroing
it out and the reason for that is that
if you have this kind of this type of
architecture that's an LS TM and you
want to basically be sharing weights
across time for each of these units then
you want the shape of the tensors shape
of the the inputs at each at each data
point to be the same and so if you want
that then you want to be able to
basically pass in pass in the same shape
but of course you don't want to give it
the ground truth label because the label
is what it's supposed to be predicting
um so the question was to zero out the
label value or the embedding value of y
I think that basically as long as you're
not passing in Y to us is input in any
way you're you're in good shape are you
asking about can you maybe repeat your
question oh um right so you're asking
basically does this top function here is
theta an input or is it parameters in
this case it is it is the kind of the
parameters of that model and so maybe a
more standard notation would be to
either put this theta a subscript to the
P or put a semicolon here to indicate
that its parameters rather than an input
during méditerranée we're optimizing
over theta yeah in the inner loop you're
producing fine yeah
right yeah so fire yeah exactly fire is
computed at test time given the training
data set it isn't but yeah I'm let's go
let's go through a couple more of the
details here before we answer any more
questions about this so the kind of this
is uh that I discovered what the
objective is now let's actually look at
this as an algorithm so what we do is we
won't actually optimize this we first
sample a task I one of our Mediterranean
tasks or a mini batch of tasks then we
sample disjoint data sets from that task
data set which will refer to as D train
and D test so if this is all of the data
that we have for task I then what we're
going to want to do is we're gonna want
to partition this into a training data
set and a test set for that task and so
in particular what we can do is we can
basically pick randomly select half of
them to be used for the trained is that
and have them do use you for the test
set at this iteration of the algorithm
then we'll take the training data set
that what's in the green box and use
that to compute the task for its
specific parameters Phi I and then we'll
update our meta parameters using the
gradient of the objective with respect
to the meta parameters using the
computed to a specific parameters and
then we'll repeat this iteratively using
your favorite gradient descent optimizer
things like atom SGD momentum etc yeah
so so the question was we're not going
to be computing gradients using the
training data set so what we're using is
we're computing gradients using the meta
training data set of tasks and so the
top specific parameters are computed
using D train and the then we evaluate
those parameters using the test data set
for that meta training task so we've
kind of lifted the training data sets
from kind of training data sets and test
a
that some edit rating sets and meta test
house yeah you're asking a theta theta
is all meta parameters yeah so all of
theta is are the meta parameters and
then Phi are considered the Tau specific
parameters or the today that Phi is
essentially not considered part of the
meta parameters we'll get into what Phi
might be in a second it could be the
base basically it could be the the
parameters of an entire neural network
it could also be something that's more
compact and I'll talk about that in a
second yes yeah that's the MIT yeah yeah
exactly so we haven't touched any of the
meta test tasks that are kind of held
out from the TAS distribution right so
in this case for this particular network
architecture the order of the training
dataset some at the order of the data
points matters and this actually isn't
necessarily a good property because in
many cases the the you have data sets
not data lists for which the order
doesn't matter and so we'll see some
architectures that later see some
architectures were you they are
permutation invariant yeah so in this
case we compute Phi in step 3 and then
we update the meta parameters data so we
do not update Phi itself it's that is
basically dynamically computed at every
iteration of the meta training process
and then at test time we're also going
to be computing Phi given our meta
parameters theta yeah yeah so it's
similar to that so the we essentially
compute you can view the the computation
of the gradient with respect to theta as
basically back propagating the loss from
from Y into Phi back in pack all the way
into theta we don't ever use that
gradient to update Phi we only use it to
update theta but it has to go through
Phi in order to compute that gradient
I'll talk a bit about architecture is in
a minute but one of the nice one of the
things about Ellis hams and our nuns is
that they can process variable amounts
of data relatively easily so you don't
have to assume any data any particular
data set size although you should
probably trade it for the large as
possible it data set size but there are
other neural network architectures that
I'll talk about that you can use for
this as well okay so now what are the
challenges with this approach is that if
I if I is literally representing all the
parameters of another neural network it
may not be that scalable to actually
output all of those neural network
parameters because neural networks can
be very large so there are a couple of
approaches for dealing with this but the
main kind of way you can think about
doing this is you don't need a
necessarily output all of the parameters
of a neural network you could have said
just output the sufficient statistics of
that task such that you could
effectively make predictions for that
task and so what this looks like is
instead of having a neural network that
outputs all of the parameters Phi it'll
output some set of sedition statistics H
and then this like some some lower
dimensional vector H and then your your
neural network on the right will use
those sufficient statistics as well as
other parameters in theta in order to
make predictions and so what this lower
dimensional vector H might represent is
things like contextual task information
and then your new parameters Phi I are
going to correspond to H I as well as
part of theta that will parameterize G
and so essentially the way that you can
view this size is you can basically view
this if you basically V this is a single
LCM that's taking into data points so
one of the reasons why I named this H as
H is often used for the hidden state
develops I'm noti'm if you basically
share all the parameters between
F on the left and G as for example in
LST M then the task specific parameters
Phi are represented by the hidden state
of that LCM as well as the parameters of
the function on the right that are
shared with the LST M parameters so one
interesting connection here is that if
you recall multitask learning where we
were concatenated ask information Z into
the network you can view eight
essentially as a summarization of the
task that is used to make predictions
for that task so H and Z are very
similar in this case unlike Z in the
multitask learning setting we're
actually learning the task
representation H in this case and we're
learning how to produce that task
representation H given a small data set
of that task okay and so the the fully
general form of blackbox neural networks
is a function that takes as input a
train data set and a test input and
produces a test output where Phi is is
somewhere in the middle of this network
and may not actually be something that
is actually representing parameters per
se yeah
right so the question is can you explain
what Seita ji means here so here
basically theta G represents all of the
other parameters that this that this
network G is representing other than H
so this neural network right here this
making prediction about test making
predictions about test inputs will take
as input H and will also have other
parameters theta G that it will use to
make predictions theta G will be a part
of the full parameter vector theta and
it may also share parameters with this
part of the network right here yes so in
this case you might be sharing more more
parameters between test time and and
training time okay so this is the kind
of overview of blackbox approaches and
let's talk about what sort of
architectures we could use for this
function f so one of the first well I
guess it's hard to say what what came
comes first with research in general but
one of the earlier approaches to these
sorts of blackbox approaches is using L
STM's or neural Turing machines that
take as input the test inputs and
basically the data set and be able to
make and use that to make predictions
about new data points l STM's are
probably something that's familiar to
you neural Turing machines are something
that have more of an external memory
mechanism for which it can essentially
store information about the training
data points and then access that
information when making predictions
about new data points and it does this
in a differentiable way you can also use
something that so as was noted before
this is not permutation invariant
because they're taking in the data
points sequentially and you could also
use an architecture that is permutation
invariant by having a
feed forward function that takes as
input each of your train data points x
and y x1 y1 x2 y2 etc and then
aggregates that information using
something like an average operation to
compute something that looks like in
this case what's denoted as a or R and
then that is passed into another
feed-forward network to make predictions
about new data points beyond these these
2 types of architectures there's a wide
range of others that have been proposed
that I've used other memory mechanisms
as well in combination with ideas from
kind of having slower weights and faster
weights often when people use the term
slow weights and fast weights they refer
to the TAS specific parameters as fast
weights and the meta parameters as slow
weights because one of them is updated
much more quickly than the other one
this is a concept that was developed by
folks in neuroscience actually that have
looked at kind of the how weights have
been changing and how how synapses
change in the brain and then there's
also an architecture that has used a
combination of attention mechanisms and
convolutions so in this case
convolutions are coaxial ii going to be
not permutation invariant although
attention based architectures can be
permutation invariant and as a
representative approach of kind of
blackbox approaches in general these
this type of method that uses that uses
convolutions and attentions is able to
do quite well on things like Omniglot
getting around 97 to 99 percent accuracy
on things ranging from 5 way one-shot to
20 way five-shot i'm gonna go out and
also does well on the mean the imagenet
data set that is performing like 5
weight classification for actually real
images from the image that data set yeah
so the question is the like is there any
mechanisms relating to neuro what do you
be my age I write okay I guess I'm not
I'm not too familiar with the the
neuroscience literature to be able to
comment on that in a in a competent way
the I guess one thing I will say that
has been somewhat inspired by the
neuroscience literature is that people
have looked at things that look like LST
M's but do more of a hebbian role update
rule on that on H on H I in order to
kind of update the sufficient statistics
with respect to a given task given your
training data sets other works from I
guess one thing that is perhaps worth
noting that we will actually cover in
one of the reading sessions is that the
I guess there are a number of
neuroscience researchers deepmind that
have looked at these types of metal
learning methods and they have focused
on on actually these types of meta
learning methods more so than
optimization based or Pat nonparametric
approaches using things like like Ellis
gems yeah
yeah so in general I'm I'm under the
opinion that Omniglot performance has
saturated for the most part so one of
the algorithms that we'll be talking
about later in this lecture gets like
99.9% accuracy on five-way five-shot
Omniglot things that aren't solved our
generation of Omniglot digits that's
certainly something that's a lot harder
and was actually proposed in the
original paper also this is a bit of a
nuance point but the méditerranée test
split that they proposed in the original
omnigul up paper is actually not the one
that's used in all the machine learning
papers because it is a bit it proposes a
trade test foot that doesn't have quite
enough training data points for these
models to not over fit a lot and so if
you're looking interested in looking at
very efficient learning then you I think
that performance isn't quite as
saturated when you move towards the
original méditerranée minute estimate
but then it's just a matter of putting
inductive bias ease into your network
okay so in homework 1 you'll be
implementing kind of the data processing
pipeline for these meta training
algorithms that involves actually taking
the Omniglot dataset for example and
actually loading images and and plugging
them into a neural network this is
actually a pretty fundamental part of
these algorithms you'll also be
implementing a very simple black box
meta learner and also training a few
shot Omniglot classifier and you can use
kind of you can someone compared to some
of the numbers in these papers ok so to
wrap up black box adaptation the pros
and cons of this approach is that first
is a very expressive so given that
neural networks are Universal function
approximator z' these methods can
represent any function of your training
dataset and they're also very easy to
combine with a variety of learning
problems for example supervised learning
and reinforcement learning and later in
this course we'll talk about how we can
combine these methods with reinforcement
learning it's it's kind of the spoiler
is that it's very straightforward as you
might have
with these types of models the downsides
of this approach is that in general
these neural networks are fairly complex
because they need to be taking in
datasets and making predictions about
new data points they essentially need to
figure out how to learn from data and
they need to do those do this in a
completely like basically completely
from scratch like an initialization
these these LST M's were not built as as
optimization procedures and they need to
learn those optimization procedures from
scratch from the Mediterranean data and
as a result they're often fairly data
inefficient and by this I mean not data
inefficient at meta test time but they
often require a large number of kind of
a large amount of meta training data at
large number of tasks in order to
perform well ok any questions on black
box approaches before we move on yeah so
I guess the so the question was there
are other elements that take X test as
input and you could certainly like you
could certainly integrate X test as much
as possible in on into the kind of
left-hand side of this diagram it's
still kind of part of the input and if
you look at have the the general form of
of these algorithms it's something that
takes in the train data set and the test
input and you can really design whatever
architecture you want to integrate those
pieces of information whether or not
they're integrated kind of somewhat
separately or treated somewhat
separately or integrated in the same
part of the network that that's up to
you ok great so let's talk about
optimization based approaches so the I
guess the motivation here is that as we
talked about a bit before if we want to
infer all of the parameters of a neural
network having a neural network output
them isn't a very
way to do that and instead what we could
do is instead of treating this function
as an inference problem we can instead
treat it as an optimization procedure
and this is similar to what we do in
supervised learning we treat parameter
like inference over parameters as an
optimization problem not as necessarily
an inference problem and this is where
authorization based my learning
approaches come in so the key idea
behind these methods is that we're gonna
acquire our top specific parameters phi
i through optimization and then we'll
differentiate through that optimization
procedure to the meta parameters to
optimize for a set of meta parameters
such that that optimization procedure
for phi i leads to good performance so
how should we get started here so the I
guess you can essentially break down the
the Mediterranean problem as as to
having these two terms one that's
maximize and likelihood of your training
data given your task specific parameters
and one that is optimizing your tests
that likely have your task specific
parameters under your meta parameters
and so you can view this kind of this
this equation right here as the
optimization procedure that you want to
be able to do at test time and also the
optimization procedure that you're going
to be integrating into your meta
learning problem during meditating one
that's basically going to be taking into
account the training data set and your
accuracy on the train data set as well
as your prior which is given by Phi
given data where your meta parameters
are parametrizing your prior all right
so your meta parameters are serving as
your prior and now we need to think
about well what form of prior should we
should we basically impose using our
meta parameters well one very successful
form of prior knowledge that we've used
in deep learning optimization is the
initialization and in particular one of
the things that's been quite successful
in deep learning is what's called
fine-tuning where we take some set of
initial parameters and then run gradient
descent on training data
for some new tasks and typically it is
not for just a single gradient stuff as
written here but for many gradient steps
and this is worked really well so for
example if you look at something that
pre trains on imagenet versus training
from scratch those are the two rows
shown here and fine tuning either on the
Pascal data set or on the Sun data set
and we see a huge difference in
performance using pre training which is
labeled as original in this paper versus
using a random initialization great so
typically this is in many ways a valid
approach to kind of the meta learning
problem where you first train for
pre-trained a set of parameters on your
meta training data and then fine tune on
your data set at test time now some
questions that might come up is where do
you get your pre training parameters the
typical way to do this is through for
provision problems that's pikal way to
do this is by pre training on image deck
classification using supervised learning
in language one very popular approach
for doing this is using models trained
on a large language corporis models like
Bert or language models or other
unsupervised learning techniques so pre
training of neural networks actually has
a very long history before even well
before image in it where people are pre
training their models using unsupervised
learning techniques and then fine-tuning
them although other than language is not
sure if it's not clear those approaches
have really been that popular recently
but really like if you have some domain
in many ways kind of a thing to do is
just to take train on some very large
and diverse data set and then fine-tune
these fine-tune those parameters on
whatever data set you actually want to
perform inference on and it's also worth
mentioning that pre train models are
often available online and so you can
actually don't even necessarily need to
do this step where you actually train on
imagenet you can just download the
parameters and then fine-tune from there
and then I guess the other thing worth
mentioning here is that fine-tuning is a
bit of an art like other other aspects
of deep learning unfortunately eivin so
there's a rain
of common practices for performing fine
tuning successfully this includes things
like fine tuning with a smaller learning
rate using a lower learning rate for
lower layers of the network typically
the low layers for many fine tune
problems typically they'll blow the
little features of the things that need
to change the least and the higher level
concepts are the things that need to
change the most for a new task you may
will actually freeze earlier layers of
network potentially even basically
setting them with setting a learning
rate of zero for those layers you could
also consider V initializing the last
layer and then typically people search
over these hyper parameters using
cross-validation and then the last thing
worth mentioning here is that
architecture choices tend to matter a
lot when we're choosing how to fine tune
for example things like residual
networks tend to be actually quite good
at fine tuning because the gradients
flow-flow relatively easily through
various parts of the network when you
have residual connections yeah so you're
asking basically when you're when you're
fine-tuning you're not actually using
any information about the target
yeah so you're saying that basically we
never are passing in any information
about the task as input to this approach
or to the blackhawks approaches yes
that's that's correct and there's
actually well for metal earning well
there's actually some nuanced reasons
for not doing that which is kind of
interesting and somewhere it seems like
in many ways you should pass in as much
information you have about a task to the
model such that it can use it but in
fine-tuning for example if you say
passed in a one hot vector for imagenet
and then passed it in a different one
hot vector for your test task then it
actually may like that information well
first if they're just two separate one
hunters like the the test tasks that
you're doing it like versus train time
they're completely distinct things to
the network and so that information
isn't something that I can actually be
used during the fine-tuning process to
to help it because it is only ever seen
one task and so kind of looking at
another task for example won't telling
it that it's doing a different task is
it go ahead
yeah yeah so you're asking me Zhu Li you
could basically tell the network like
you can train you could pre trade it on
like multitask learning say like first
you're gonna train you on like
recognizing animals and recognizing
plants and recognizing cars or something
and and tell it that it's gonna be doing
that or like fine-tune it on that for
example in this case the pre-training is
just single task and the test task is
also single task so you don't actually
tell it any information about kind of
what tasks that's solving cuz it's kind
of assumed that you're gonna be
fine-tuning it on a new task and kind of
both pre training and testing our or
separate tasks I'll get to the to the
point about why medal learning doesn't
pass and task information a bit later
yeah so in this case we're actually not
I guess the in this case this is there
isn't actually really a distinction
between tasks specific parameters and
meta parameters so what we're doing is
we're just pre training parameters theta
which which basically could be your meta
could be your meta parameters data and
then the optimization process is
producing your task specific parameters
by I would actually so I would actually
say that the the pre trade parameters
theta are the meta parameters and that
initialization is affecting is basically
serving as a prior on your optimization
in a somewhat implicit way because
basically in that the the Mediterranean
parameters are like affecting the
solution that the fine-tuning process
will give you yeah you're saying is this
is the fine-tuning procedure pruning the
network so in this case is actually just
changing the weights so it's not
removing or adding weights to the
network so you're asking what what do
what do fine tuning procedures end up
doing did it I think that the kind of
the accepted wisdom of what these are
things are doing are reusing features
and often are changing how those
features are used for a new task but not
necessarily changing the features that
much themselves so and that's kind of
how like the the leaner layers of the
network are changing a lot and the
features themselves are not changing a
lot although I don't know if anyone has
actually proven anything related to that
yeah yeah so typically you'll use the
same architecture or you might use the
same architecture but like chop off the
last layer right so we'll get we'll get
how we can integrate this into a meta
learning approach on the next slide
but yeah so typically what you do is you
just pre-trained parameters on a single
task and then fine tune on your test
tasks okay great so what another example
of where this has been used is using
basically pre training using language
models and then fine tuning on text
classification tasks and the postern
here are pretty interesting
they're showing that on the x-axis as
you vary the number of training examples
you have for the test ask how does the
performance on that task vary and so
what we see first is that there's a big
difference between training from scratch
versus training using pre trained
parameters from universal language
models or u LM so that's the gap between
the blue lines and the orange and green
lines and then the second thing that we
see is that as you have fewer examples
in your new task data set performance
gets worse our error goes up and so
essentially what we see is that when you
only have for example 100 data points
for your test a skier your performance
actually isn't very good on your test
task and you can expect that as you
actually decrease that even lower
you would do even worse and so
essentially fine tuning is much less
effective when you have smaller data
sets and now motivated by this how about
we design a meta learning algorithm with
the goal of being able to fine tune with
small amounts of data at test time and
I'm pretty clear what we could try to do
is take our fine tuning procedure and
the Holly weight how well those task
specific parameters did on a test data
set on new data points and then actually
optimize for your pre trained parameters
such that fine tuning gives you a set of
tests gives you a set of parameters that
do well on the test data points and you
could do this optimization across all of
the tasks in your meta training time in
your meditating data set such that fine
tuning with small amounts of data leads
to good generalization
so essentially it'll be training for a
set of parameters theta across many
different tasks such that they can
transfer effectively via fine tuning ok
so kind of at a more intuitive level
what this might look like is say theta
is a parameter vector that your meta
learning your meta parameters and Phi I
star is the optimal parameter vector for
task III then you can view the
meditating process of this optimization
as the thick black line
where when you're at this point during
the Mediterranean process and you take a
gradient step with respect to toss three
you're quite far from the optimum for
toss three whereas at the end of the
Mediterranean process you take a
gradient separate this with the toss
three you're quite close to the optimum
and likewise for a range of other tasks
and we refer to this as the model
agnostic mental learning algorithm in
the sense that it embeds this
optimization procedure in a way that's
agnostic to the model that's used and
the loss function that's used as long as
both of them are amenable to gradient
based optimization and then one other
thing worth noting here is that this
this diagram I think can be helpful for
getting across the intuition of the
method but at the same time it can be a
bit misleading
first because parameter vectors do not
exist in two dimensions and also or
neural network parameters do not exist
in two dimensions typically and then
also there often isn't a single optimum
but but actually a whole space of
Optimum's for or a whole space of Optima
for neural network parameters and so in
many ways is more about not necessarily
reaching a center point for these
different algorithms but reaching a
point such that fine-tuning will
eventually will get you to a good part
of the parameter space with with small
amounts of data okay so that was the
objective what does this look like as an
algorithm so we can take the black box
adaptation approach that we mentioned
before and adapt it to the optimization
based metal learning case and
essentially what this does is you first
sample a task you can you sample your
datasets then instead of computing your
top specific parameters using a neural
network you're going to be computing
them using one or a few steps of fine
tuning and then you update your meta
parameters by differentiating through
those fine tuning steps into your into
the parameter vector theta into your
initial set of parameters okay any
questions on this before I get into a
few of the details yeah
so you're asking what if you use
multi-touch learning as an
initialization instead I see so you're
saying that you could basically
pre-trained do this military process to
get in this initial set of weights and
then use that as an initialization for
multitask learning you could certainly
do that I guess what this is doing is is
optimizing that the meta the meta
learning process that I mentioned on the
previous slide is optimizing for faceted
patient to individual tasks given an
individual data set you could also do
the same thing for pairs of tasks or
triplets of tasks if you wanted to
explicitly pre-trained for 3-shot
learning or it's not for each other and
three tasks learning you could I guess
you could also consider doing something
like optimizing it for optimizing it on
on for a single task adaptation and then
fine-tuning it on multi task allocation
or multi task learning it's hard to say
how well that would do because it's not
actually explicitly training for what
it's going to be doing at test time but
it conceivably could do something yeah
was that just motivation for this
algorithm right so in this case we start
with a random initialization before this
Mediterranean algorithm and I was mostly
serving as basically as motivation for
how well pre-training could work in a
random settings yeah yeah so this
approach actually works really well even
for one-shot learning to shot learning
it's a true it's competitive with with
the black box approaches that I've
mentioned previously right so for the
one-shot setting you can you typically
that Vidur optimization is somewhere
between one and five gradient stops I
mean even with only a few gradient steps
you can get quite far okay so one thing
worth mentioning about this algorithm is
that it brings up second order
derivatives because we are optimizing
basically because we're we're optimizing
for a set of meta parameters so this is
cut we have this gradient and inside of
this objective term we also have this
gradient right here so now you might be
a little bit worried about this so for
example if we need to compute the full
Hessian of the neural network we would
be in a bit of trouble and what if we
want more than one inner gradient step
does that give us higher order higher
order derivatives and so I want to go
through a bit on the white board what
this what actually the meta gradient
update looks like such that we can kind
of figure out the answers to these
questions great so let's say that for
the sake of notation so in this case I
was writing out a gradient step as the
update procedure and in this case I'm
just going to use you to denote the
update rule and that's going to be a
function of theta and
your training data points d-train so
this is this is basically one or a few
steps of gradient descent theta minus
alpha grad theta lost with respect to D
train and I'm going to use a so you kind
of just write out some some notation I'm
going to use D to denote the total
derivatives and the table symbol to
denote partial derivatives and we'll see
why this distinction actually matters in
a second and this is just for the
purpose of the white board and all the
slides will just be using the novelist's
and both the gradient symbol for both
okay so as you can see on the the bottom
of this slide the optimization procedure
that we have looks something like an
optimization over our meta parameters
data over our loss function with respect
to our top specific parameters Phi and
our test data points I'm gonna drop the
eye from the notation here just for
notational simplicity and this is the
same as an optimization over meta
parameters of L of our update rule with
regard to our training data set and our
test data set okay so this should all be
clear from the board and in order to
optimize the subjective function we need
to be able to get the derivatives of
this objective with respect to our meta
parameters if we want to optimize this
with gradient based optimization things
like atom for example and so to do this
we need to be able to get the
derivatives of this objective with
respect to our meta parameters data and
so let's try to actually write out what
this meta gradient looks like so in
particular we can view this meta
gradient first we can basically compute
the
with the chain rule you can beat the
derivative of the outer function and
then use the chain rule to compute the
derivative of the the inside with
respect to theta so what this looks like
is we'll take the derivative with
respect to I'll use kind of a
placeholder variable Phi bar of L Phi
bar and D test evaluated at Phi bar
equals U of of theta comma D train so
this is just the derivative of the outer
objective times the derivative of the
the derivative of the update rule what's
the stock did you train yeah yes I can
try to write larger from here forward so
basically this is the the derivative the
derivative of the outer loss and then
this is D Phi D theta this is y partial
derivatives are matters if we kind of
just wrote this as as a full derivative
then this would just be exactly the same
as the or basically be very similar to
the UM to the what was originally
written okay right great so notice that
this is uh this is like a row vector I
need a right bigger and this is a matrix
and so the result is a row vector this
can be computed with a single backward
pass through the neural network so this
is I can just set the parameters of your
neural network to five bar and then
compute the derivative of this loss
function with respect to those
parameters so this is just one backward
pass this is differentiating through the
update process itself so this is the
part that is a little bit trickier to
deal with okay so let's try to actually
compute what this looks like so we can
let
you theta D train let's just start with
the case where we have a single gradient
step then in this case then we can try
to take the derivative of this so
derivative of the update rule with
respect to theta this is going to equal
the identity matrix minus alpha D G
theta squared of L of theta comma D
train
and this is the this is the Hessian of
the neural network any questions with
this ok so if we then plug this term
into here then what we get is that we
this is we have this vector we
essentially need to be doing a doing a
vector matrix multiplication and
fortunately this means that we don't
actually have to compute the full
Hessian of the neural network because we
have because we have this all we need to
compute is this Hessian vector product
and there are much more efficient ways
to compute Hessian vector products via
back propagation for neural networks
then that don't require you to construct
the entire Hessian of the neural network
and it also turns out the standard
neural network different automatic
differentiation libraries like tensor
flow and PI ports will actually perform
this high-fashion vector computation for
you such that you in an efficient way
that amounts to essentially performing
additional backward passes such that you
don't actually have to worry about
coding this up yourself which is very
convenient
ok so that's the case if we have just a
single neural a single little gradient
stop in the in the inner loop what if we
have
multiple inter gradients up to the inner
loop and so in particular what if we
have you theta comma D train what if we
have two gradients up so this is going
to equal theta minus alpha D theta L
theta D train let's call this
intermediate set of parameters theta
Prime and then we will have a second
gradient step that is with respect to
theta prime of L of theta prime D train
alright so this is two gradient stops if
we then want to compute the derivative
of this then what we get is we first get
the first two terms that we had before
which is the identity minus the minus
the Hessian and then what about the
second term so we want to compute the
derivative of this last term with
respect to the parameters theta and what
this looks like is first you compute the
derivative of the outside so you get D
theta prime squared and all used in a
bar here of theta bar do you train this
is going to be evaluated at theta prime
times D theta prime D theta and so first
this this term right here is just equal
to the first two terms and one that I
think that we get here is that we don't
get third order terms here so we get the
evaluate at theta prime which is the
parameters after the first gradient step
and we get the Hessian with respect to
the original parameters but we don't get
anything any third order derivatives
basically and again this is something
that we can efficiently compute well if
this is like basically compete with
additional backward passes without
having to basically construct an equal
Hessians or without having to compete at
higher order derivatives which is nice
ok and then as you might imagine if you
continue to run this continue to compute
this for for even more gradient steps in
the inner loop you basically continue to
get these types of terms that pop up
without higher order terms okay any
questions on on some of the math okay so
yeah so if you're trying to
differentiate this third term with
respect to theta you first take the
derivative of the outer function with
respect to its arguments times the times
this term which is the Pieta chain rule
all right and sorry that this likes to
float upward but okay cool so now we've
talked about optimization optimization
based approaches or at least the kind of
the basics of them let's think about how
they compare to block locks pressures so
can view black box on a patient as
having this general form that takes as
input a training data set and a test
input for example using something like a
recurrent neural network or something
like that now you could also view
mammal or mall agnostic meta learning is
also taking in a train dataset in a
testament where you have this function
fide that takes us and put the test
input and the parameters Phi are
computed with gradient descent so
essentially you can view mammal as a
computation graph with this funny
embedded gradient operator inside that
computation graph so if you kind of take
this view that means you can potentially
mix and match components of of these
approaches for example one paper is
looked at can you learn in this
initialization but replace the gradient
update that mammal does with an learn
neural network that produces that
gradient update so for example instead
of having instead of learning the
initialization than running gradient
decide you could learn initialization
and have a neural network output your
your gradient update and this was done
in Ravi and La Rochelle and 2017 and
this paper actually proceeds the the
mammal paper but I mention it here just
for the purpose of understanding
different things ok and this computation
craft you have been learning will come
back again later ok now one other thing
to think about is some of like how these
approaches not just compare conceptually
but also in practice and in theory so
one question to think about those
actually mentioned a bit before is what
if your test task is different than the
meta training tasks that you were
optimizing on and so this is a question
that we studied empirically to some
degree and we were aiming to compare
mammal to black box type approaches such
as snail that the the architecture that
used attention and convolutions as well
as meta networks which is also one of
the architectures that I showed before
and we looked at Omni classification
where we tried to vary the tasks and see
how the performance did as you vary the
tasks away from the meta to training
distribution so in this case the x-axis
will show the task variability and the
y-axis is going to show
performance and so in the first thing we
looked at we we skewed the digits and
the Omniglot dataset so it was trained
on digits that were kind of in the
center and then we moved kind of away
from the Mediterranean task distribution
trading it on our testing yes ability to
adapt to tasks that involve skewed
digits and what we saw at first is that
all the approaches that their
performance deteriorated as you moved
away from the Mediterranean distribution
but we saw that algorithms like mammal
are better able to perform these out of
distribution tasks as you move away from
the net trained astre bution because
they're performing an optimization
procedure at test time so because you're
running grain descent at test time you
can still expect it to give you some
reasonable answer at least an answer
that that achieves good accuracy on the
training data set for example whereas
blackbox approaches that are just taking
in a dataset as input in producing an
answer when you move away from the
training distribution there's really
nothing that you can say about what
those algorithms are doing because they
yeah yeah and then if you look at
something like the scale of the digits
we also see this sharp drop-off as you
move away from the training
Mediterranean dataset but we kind of
consistently saw this pattern that
optimization based approaches were
better extrapolating because they were
still giving you a procedure at test
time that looked like an optimization
procedure so this is one empirical trend
that we noticed and they might ask well
for embedding the structure of
optimization into the Mediterranean
process does this come at a cost and a
particular one very natural thing that
was actually brought up a bit before is
how far can you actually get with a
single gradients that for a few
gradients ups are these methods actually
as expressive as the black box
approaches that I mentioned before and
it turns out that you can show that for
sufficiently deep function f the mammal
algorithm the man will function that I
mentioned before can approximate any
function of the training data set and
the test input it can basically
represent anything that the black box
approaches can represent under a few
fairly mild assumptions under the
assumptions that
the inner learning rate is nonzero that
the loss function gradient doesn't lose
information about the label the standard
like mean squared error and cross that
repeat loss functions fall under this
category and also that the data points
in your training dataset are unique and
the reason why this is interesting is
that it means that mammal has the
benefit of the inductive bias of
gradient descent without losing
expressive power yeah what I mean by
that is that at initialization like even
before you do any Mediterranean for
mammal you're still have an optimization
procedure that's going to point you
roughly in the right direction so you're
still running gradient descent and
you'll still be able to improve on your
training data yeah this is actually only
for a single gradients dug very deep
exponential yeah so the the the I guess
the assumptions are realistic you are
very mild the sufficiently deep function
is is not mild it does need to be very
deep and you could probably relax this
assumption if you made other assumptions
about the gradient pointing in the right
direction or other things about the
optimization yeah yeah okay so we're
running out of time the let's see one
thing I want to mention I guess we can
probably just leave off we're leave off
where I left off on Monday next week but
we basically covered the basics of
optimization based better learning and
I'll cover I'll cover the rest of it and
some of that go into a bit more of the
advanced topics on Monday next week on
Wednesday this week we have applications
of meta learning and multitask
to think about imitation learning and
generative models drug discovery and
machine translation I think that this
will actually be pretty exciting so
we'll actually see some of the
real-world use cases of these algorithms
these will be student presentations and
discussions and then on Monday I'll wrap
up optimization based on learning and
cover nonparametric methods and talk
about how all these different approaches
compare great I'll see you on Wednesday